Wow you really came out of nowhere
what no no I was stopped at that stop
sign yeah listen let's just exchange
information and have our insurance
companies take care of it right yeah I'm
gonna get my info yes please
I don't know what are you doing what are
you doing huh why did you start the
engine
what engine the engine of your car did I
yes I was just trying to get the
information for you from the glove box
do you need to start your car to open
your glove compartment ah yeah okay you
know what how about I just I get your
insurance information now all right sure
hey hey hey hey stop stop stop stop
where the hell are you going nowhere
give me the information right now okay
right now do you understand okay
all right sorry I I misunderstood I
don't see how all right here it is no no
I know your your insurance information I
just did this is a Walgreens receipt Oh
oh here it is
license to fart
what is that that nunya now you're just
miming you know what give me your
insurance information right now I'm
calling the cop
okay good I'm sorry I'm sorry that's
just that's my personality I was messing
with you I apologize I thought you were
gonna take off and flee the scene
yeah no I'm not whoa then how am I gonna
get my car fixed hey we just an accident
it's obviously not the time or the place
so I'm sorry
here you go here it is I mean can you
imagine though yeah that you were gonna
take off yeah I can't imagine that it's
giving me chills on the [ __ ] spine
anyway here's the real insurance card
and we know what you think official
laminated license to [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you